[Music]
indonesia was one of the first
developing nations to launch a covid
vaccine drive
but that early push has started to
falter
bogged down by geography and logistical
problems
that's forced the government to get
creative
taking the vaccine directly to those who
need it
but it's not just people's lives that
are at stake
covet threatens their livelihoods as
well
poverty was already spreading here
before kovid shocked the system
but now it has created fresh economic
divides
leaving many wondering how to put food
on the table during a global pandemic
this is your kovid 19 special on dw i'm
janelle dumalaon
after weeks of a surge in kovid 19 cases
the spread is now slowing somewhat in
indonesia but the country continues to
struggle with the worst effects of the
pandemic growing inequality being just
one of them
the pressure is on indonesia aims to
vaccinate one million people a day
and since the arrival of the delta
variant everybody here is keen to get
the jab
among them demas and his family the
pandemic has hit thousands of low-income
families like his particularly hard he
used to have a small shop in bakassi
just outside jakarta
we now have nothing left i was made
redundant and now we're effectively
bankrupt we're trying to find a way out
my wife is baking and tries to sell
homemade cakes online
indonesia began its covert 19
vaccination program this january using
vaccine components from china indonesia
has produced 185 million doses of the
synovac vaccine to date
the country has also received over 19
million vaccine doses from the united
nations backed kovacs initiative
with a number of new infections sky high
across indonesia vaccine skeptics have
become hard to find
i don't want the vaccine because there's
so much bad news about it i'm just
worried for my health
a lot of my friends got sick after being
vaccinated so i'm afraid
to stop rumors about exaggerated side
effects the government has started an
information campaign the ministry of
health is determined to vaccinate 70
percent of the population from the age
of 12 by the end of the year
if you don't believe that kovid is real
just come to the hospital
or the cemetery
and help the officers bury people
without protection
in a viral video two self-proclaimed
healers did just that the two visited
covid patients a few months ago in order
to prove the disease is not dangerous
both of them died a few weeks later
there should be more sympathy with the
victims we need to acknowledge the
enormous death toll worldwide and
particularly in indonesia
among them are many of dimas friends
he's glad to have some protection now
in one month he will receive his second
shot
aloysius
is a lecturer in economics at the atma
jaya yoga karta university welcome to
the program we're hearing of overloaded
hospitals deaths and destroyed
livelihoods can you tell us how bad it
really is on the ground
actually
after the government implemented several
lockdown measures and other physical
distancing
of course still continues yeah but
better
occupancy rates vor
now according to ministry of health in
all province
is lower than 70 percent yeah so it's
indicate that hospitals are not
overloaded again yeah but
and specifically uh
yesterday this uh
vertical pencil rate is uh 29 yeah but
in some provinces especially in uh
sulawesi sumatra and kalimantan are
still above
50 indicating that now the problem
outside of japan islands is still
serious yeah
and
regions in
bali and yogyakarta province are still
under lockdown level four yeah
right now we also want to talk a bit
about the economy how have people who
work in the informal sector been
affected by the pandemic
yeah we know that before this coffee 19
pending actually
maybe more offices
more than half of indonesian workforce
yeah they got their income from their
activities in the informal sectors yeah
and
these sectors it's really none that
always face vulnerability in terms of
unsecured job is also uh
unstable income yeah and most of the
poor are in this sector yeah so
when
there is a strict physical dispensing
and all lockdown measures
this directly affected the directivity
of this improv worker such as street
vending and also
transport drivers yeah so
they
uh
face difficulty to to get income yeah
yes right actually we don't have uh yeah
okay the pandemic is disproportionately
affecting the poor and those who work in
the informal sector but does the picture
differ depending on whether we're
talking about rural or urban areas
informal sectors mainly exist in urban
area yeah and
people's from
rurals yeah they moved to the city in
order to find another jobs another life
something like this yeah and
when something happened like this a very
strong job yeah
they have no
sufficient support
and one important thing that it's very
difficult to reach this worker is that
informal worker is not
fully recorded by governments yeah so
when government try to to have for
instance to provide subsidy for instance
there is a problem with administrative
matter for instance
the
the id the location something like this
yeah so
uh
it's difficult actually to to know the
the rate of the the income fall but
one study indicates that at least
now their income already dropped
maybe 80 percent yeah
since the start of this spending
so there are bureaucratic difficulties
involved in getting aid to especially
informal workers and the poor but i also
wanted to ask about indonesia's
vaccination strategy it of course
differed from that of many other
countries and that the younger working
population was vaccinated first as
opposed to the elderly given what we
know today was this the right strategy
actually it's difficult to to say
this is a wrong strategy or a bad
strategy but in my opinion yes in the
number of questions is very limited
because we know that indonesia is not
the producers of these patients yeah
so the availability of this
presence uh
really affect the available strategy
yeah so
available strategies i think it's very
limited yeah so
uh although maybe it is not very good
strategy i think it's already a good
step yeah and basically uh the
government tried to to distribute these
questions yeah into
four steps yeah the first for worker in
health sector
and the next for the all people and
other public servants including uh
buddhists journalists and teachers and
the last as
other groups but sin a few months ago uh
the target i'm sorry that's all the time
we have for you so sorry to have to cut
you off there but
lecturer in economics thank you very
much
time now for one of your questions over
to our science correspondent derek
williams my son refuses to be vaccinated
because he says none of the vaccines are
100 approved how should i respond
well you can start by telling him that
the pfizer biontech vaccine is now fully
approved at least by the food and drug
administration in the u.s
for those over 16.
it received that designation earlier
this week more than nine months after it
was approved for emergency use there
other vaccines authorized for emergency
use or conditional use
in the u.s or in other countries they
still have to clear final hurdles to
full approval so
why does it take so long well
before issuing full approval
healthcare regulators take a really
exhaustive look at how the vaccines have
performed in real world conditions and
and whether they're living up to the
promise that was only indicated in
clinical trials
but regulators actually do that kind of
deep dig down for every new medication
or vaccine so the fact that it's taking
time
for pre-authorized vaccines to receive
full approval
isn't really a surprise or an exception
more than 5 billion doses of vaccine
have been administered globally so far
and although some
rare safety issues have been spotted for
different vaccines
that's actually a good thing because it
means the system is catching the warning
signals
that it was designed to detect
now pretty much everyone who's
vaccinated i guess has by now
argued with someone who's skeptical
about vaccines and and it's an issue
that has destroyed
plenty of relationships so so any
discussion with your son
is certain to be fraught francisco but i
i guess the one thing i always try to
communicate clearly
is that full approval is slow to come
not because i think authorities like
those at the ema and fda
are really hesitant or doubtful about
the safety and effectiveness of
pre-approved vaccines at this point
but because they're being extremely
thorough which
is really exactly how we want them to be
thanks for watching
[Music]
you